hi it's john um
i'm just planting some sweet corn uh
i bought several packets
and this is the one i gonna plant today
there we go it's uh
unwinds sweetcorn
super sweet f1 hybrid
on the pack here it says pack to your
ending
12 14
so it's all right it's in date
best before
2016. approximate seeds 35
well there was only
28. i mean that is bad
if i was selling stuff i would always
make sure there was more than what was
said
i think i i'm not sure i might contact
them to tell them there was only 28
seats
but one of the things i forgot to do
when you're in the shop and you're
buying a pack of seeds
and it says it's so just check
you can just check you can feel how many
there are and if it doesn't feel like
there's 28 in there or if have 35 in
there
don't buy it but i forgot to do that on
this one
um
whether they would send me another pack
i don't know
anyway got 28 i've got these containers
all fitted up with soil
it's just uh
i'm not quite sure what soil it is i
just found it outside um
i don't think you need very special soil
for sweet corn
um
just the warmth really
uh
i've got a pop
pot here to put any objects of stones
and things i find
so i've put one in each pot
um
uh and it says half an inch deep
so this has got twelve sets uh
just pop them in
and what they need they need warmth
so they need to be over
60 degrees
to be um
to germinate
that's the main thing they need
and then of course they need to be out
in the best of the
summer weather
they need the sunshine as the kellogg's
corn flakes advert says they need 100
days of sunshine
well sometimes we get a nice lot of
sunshine and sometimes we don't
if you get a good year you can get lots
of sweetcorn
and any surplus will be very useful for
feeding the chickens so
that's my thinking
last year i grew
some sweet corn
and just some odd bits of maize that i
had about
but uh
i bought quite a lot of seeds this time
so
it all should all be sweet cornable you
know edible
because the maze can be a bit
bitter
or
not sweet
it's with sweet corn it says you've got
to plant plants about 15 inches apart
that's quite loud and uh
and plant them in a block so they're
fertilize one another
and it also says that you shouldn't
plant other sweet corn by it
because you get cross pollination i
don't did that matter i don't know
anyway
i'd love to see i'm not quite sure
where about someone planted yet
but
it is a lovely thing to have in the
garden because
well if you just eat and eat it can't
you and children like it as well so on
these will like it
she stays with us
and um
yeah
if i do write to one wins about the one
being 28 seeds i can put a link in
to this video
um
i don't know whether that would prove
that there were only 28.
i'm not gonna just poke this one in
somewhere
but
that would
prove something do you think i mean am i
mean
i think it's a matter of principle i
mean last year i bought some other
animal seeds
and there was supposed to be about six
small net gourds in the packet
and
seeds
and there was only two
and uh
i didn't send two of them then i said to
then i bought another packet and there
was about 12 in there
i mean what it suggests to me is that
their workers just aren't interested in
getting the right amount of
seeds in the packet
which doesn't sound very good to me
anyway that's got them in there i've got
them in uh they're 12 minutes i've got
them in 24 so i may have doubled up to
see two couple
there we go just hope that they
grow i think i think within about
10 days they should be showing some
signs i think 10 days it definitely will
be
and i'll do an update then
unwinds sweetcorn and if i do send to
them i'll be able to tell you
what their response was
okay bye for now
you